There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
to test for ourselves.
I've never tried a product
from Jane Iredale before,
but this one intrigued me.
This is the HydroPure tinted serum.
It's a serum with a bunch
of pigment beads inside
that are meant to give you light coverage.
You're supposed to mix this
with your fingers first
to break up the beads,
then apply with your fingers.
I really don't like finger
applications for foundations,
but it really was the best
way to apply this product.
It did not look great
when I tried it with
a brush and my sponge.
The coverage is definitely light.
I feel like it looked like
I had no makeup on at all.
I was hoping it would feel moisturizing,
but it felt like nothing on my skin.
All my other makeup went
on top of this just fine,
and I really liked how
my skin was looking.
It's so expensive, but
I think this is great
for people who want a very
natural-looking skin tint.
Charlotte Tilbury released
these Hypnotising Pop Shot single shadows.
The packaging on this is so cute.
This is meant to be a
super-glittery, pigmented,
multidimensional shadow.
This was really easy to apply.
I just swiped it on with my finger
and blended out the edges.
I did get a tiny bit of fallout,
but I was able to just brush it away.
I really love the sparkly,
shifty effect you get with this formula.
You can definitely get a similar effect
with one of those ColourPop
Super Shock shadows,
but this formula is really
beautiful on the eyes.
Rare Beauty just released a powder version
of its super-popular highlighters.
I've been seeing some
conflicting statements
about whether this product looks glittery.
There is definitely some
superfine glitter in this formula,
but I don't think it looks
glittery on the skin.
The glow is obviously
there, and it's so pretty.
It's almost wet-looking.
I actually thought it
emphasized my texture a bit
when I first tried it.
When I tried it the second time,
I just went in with a little less product,
and it looked better.
I don't think this is as natural-looking
as the liquid version,
but it's still a really nice highlighter.
I tried a couple new
Fenty products this month:
the Plush Puddin'
Intensive Recovery lip mask
and the Glossy Posse Volume 5.0.
Let's talk about the lip mask first.
The packaging is really cool.
You twist it and the product
dispenses from the top,
so you don't have to dip into it.
The formula is very thick,
which I personally love.
It just feels so moisturizing
and plush on the lips.
It also gave this really nice
shine I wasn't expecting.
I did wear this lip
mask for a couple nights
to see if it helped with my dryness,
and I saw the difference.
My lips were so much
more soft and hydrated,
so I am definitely going
to keep using this.
Now on to the Glossy Posse Volume 5.0.
Fenty Beauty does these gloss sets
for the holiday season every year,
usually with a
limited-edition shade inside.
This set contains a gloss
bomb cream in Cupcakin',
a gloss bomb heat in Fenty Glow Heat,
and a regular gloss bomb in Fuchsia Flex.
Cupcakin' is a really pigmented gloss,
and Fenty Glow Heat gives
you that kind of spicy,
tingly lip plumping.
Fuchsia Flex is the specific
shade that's been going viral.
It's Fenty's regular gloss formula
in this really beautiful deep pink
that has a ton of glitter in it.
All of these formulas
feel so good on the lips.
Fenty does not miss
with its gloss formula.
People have been raving about
the Kosas Revealer Concealer forever,
so I finally got it.
It's supposed to be medium
coverage and super creamy.
This concealer was easy to work with
and blended out so quickly and easily.
The coverage looked a bit
lighter than medium to me,
but it covered enough.
I would go in with a
little more next time,
but I loved how this looked.
I also got the Cloud Set setting powder,
which people also really love.
I used my puff to apply this,
and it smoothed everything
out almost instantly.
I was so impressed by this powder,
and I usually hate pressed powders.
I never use them, let
alone to set my concealer,
but this looked so nice.
I used it on the rest of my face too,
and it just gave this
really soft, blurred look.
It mattified, but not too much.
I loved these two products,
especially together.
This is the Hourglass Cosmetics
Phantom Volumizing glossy balm.
It's supposed to be a
lip balm, lip plumper,
and a lip gloss all in one product.
These applied nicely,
but because this formula is so fragile,
it's easy to apply too much.
I had to smooth the product out
with my finger a couple times,
but other than that, I loved these.
They have this really nice cooling effect.
They do feel like a
super-moisturizing lip balm,
and they have this high-shine
finish, like a gloss.
It didn't do much for
me in terms of plumping,
so I think if that's the main thing
you want from a lip
product, don't get this one.
I did a little haul at ELF,
and I got some new products
and some products I've
been wanting to try.
First up is this ELF
luminous putty bronzer.
This goes from a putty
formula to a powder.
Up close, you can see a
lot of shimmer in this,
but it doesn't look that way on the skin.
This is one of the most blendable
bronzers I've ever tried.
Like, it takes no time
at all to blend this out,
and it brings a really
natural warmth to the skin.
This was so good.
Next, I tried the Halo Glow powder puff,
which is always out of stock.
People love this.
I thought it wasn't
going to be any different
to my normal powder puffs, but it is.
It's much thicker and softer
than these cheap ones I buy.
It does pick up a lot of product,
but I just evened it out
on the back of my hand.
This did such a nice job
of applying my powder.
Next, I tried the Lash 'N Roll mascara,
which kind of reminds me
of the Benefit Roller Lash.
I usually hate silicone-brush mascaras,
but I actually like how this
one applied the product.
It felt like it got every single lash.
My lashes are so straight, but
this gave them a nice curl.
I wish it thickened my
lashes more, but for 6 bucks,
this is a really good drugstore mascara.
The last product I tested
was the glossy lip stain.
I can't believe I've
never tried these before.
This formula is so interesting.
It feels like water on the lips.
Like, hydrating but also weightless.
These are a bit patchy.
There were some areas where it looked
like the product wasn't sticking.
After letting the product
sit for a few minutes,
I removed it, and it definitely
did leave a stain behind,
but the stain also looked patchy.
I do like how this
formula feels on the lips,
but it doesn't apply evenly.
For the most part, though,
this was a pretty good haul.